lors de son allocution télévisée mardi
soir le président de la république a
affiché son souhait de casser à la
racine les chaînes de contamination en
ciblant davantage les cas contacts et
les personnes testées positives locaux
vides 19 je souhaite que le gouvernement
et le parlement prévoit les conditions
pour s'assurer de l'isolément des
personnes contaminées aient compris de
manière plus contraignante
dans la foulée des parlementaires du
groupe agir ensemble qui fait partie de
la majorité présidentielle à l'assemblée
nationale ont déposé une proposition de
loi le texte vise à rendre les allemands
plus strictes tout en intégrant des
compensations financières
l'article 3 rendrait obligatoire l'
isolement des personnes positives au co
vite 19 et des cas contacts tout en
sanctionnant son non respect selon les
informations rapportées par plusieurs
sources journalistiques l'amande
pourrait s'élever à 1500 euros en cas de
manquement et une gratification de 30
euros par jour pourrait être accordée
aux personnes contraintes de s'isoler
le porte parole du gouvernement a
apporté quelques précisions lors de sa
conférence de presse à la sortie du
conseil des ministres sur la dimension
de la protection et donc de l' isolement
l'objectif est d'être plus efficace
c'est à dire que les règles soient mieux
comprise sans doute mieux expliquer sans
doute expliquer de manière plus forte y
compris en présentiel en me se rendant
au domicile de personnes qui sont
contaminées pour les accompagner et
qu'elles soient plus effective possible
le mans en étant contraignante avec une
obligation légale
possiblement si on pousse le
raisonnement une sanction vous regardez
là aussi ce qui se fait chez nos voisins
dont un certain nombre de pays qui nous
entourent si ce n'est la majorité des
pays qui nous entourent
il ya aujourd'hui une obligation légale
à s'isoler c'est vrai que plusieurs pays
européens ont déjà pris des mesures
similaires en italie en allemagne et au
royaume uni ce qui ne respectent pas les
allemands peuvent être verbalisés
les montants s'élèvent jusqu'à 5000
euros et peuvent atteindre des sommes
bien plus importantes en cas de récidive
en espagne par exemple
cette somme peut atteindre 600 mille
euros pour quelqu'un qui aurait enfreint
à plusieurs reprises
l'obligation dit
le mans en france un débat parlementaire
devra donc fixer les détails de ce
dispositif sur la table depuis déjà
plusieurs semaines dispositif qui semble
être un objectif de l'exécutif dans le
cadre de sa stratégie de déconfinement